Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call any time of day.
That number is two one nine two.
David P.
This is a really interesting voicemail.
This caller is a mental health professional.
Now, I know some of you were going to hear
the name Amanda Love and you're going to say,
that's the joke.
You know, it's the joke.
It's a man to love.
No, this is really this person's name.
We made sure that this is really a mental
health professional.
We found that they are a licensed mental health
professional in their state.
They are weighing in on what I said about
at what point do we see these delusional Trumpists
and say not to excuse their behavior and not
to ridicule mental illness?
At what point do we say this is mental illness?
And Amanda, who called in and works in this
field, has very interesting insights about
it.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, my name's Amanda Love
and I'm a mental health professional.
I just wanted to follow up with you about
when you're showing the Trump supporters and
ask him whether they might be actually mentally
ill.
And some of what I saw could be classified
as delusional, which is false.
Under the psychotic realm of mental illness,
some delusions are fixed and pretty much impossible
to eradicate.
Even with medication?
Indeed.
So yeah, I'm keeping a close eye on that too,
because some of it is definitely mentally
ill people that we're dealing with, in which
case, you know, they're not being treated
or whatever that case may be.
But I appreciate everything you do, and I
love all the information that you're putting
out there.
So thanks for what you do, and I'll keep watching.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
So listen, Amanda is not.
I know I'll get e-mails, David.
Amanda shouldn't really be diagnosing anybody
over the internet matters is not diagnosing
anybody.
What she's talking about is that, generally
speaking, some of the beliefs of these Trump
supporters are what we would call delusional
beliefs.
These are these are delusional people that
falls under the general category of psychosis.
And as someone who you know, many mental health
professionals in my family from licensed mental
health counselors, psychologists and psychiatrists,
a lot of these beliefs are very resistant
to revision from treatment with medication
and even even from psychotherapy.
These these can be very stubborn and recalcitrant
types of beliefs.
Now, I think it is important to mention that
a lot of these Trump people, you know, they
believe the Q and on stuff they believe Joe
Biden was killed and replaced with a body
double.
They believe, you know, all all of this different
stuff, OK, with a lot of these people.
It just so happens that their beliefs relate
to Trump and many of these folks absent Trump,
if Trump didn't exist, if Trump hadn't been
president and it didn't start all of this,
this chain of events that has taken place
over the last five to six years, many close
to seven years now, many of these people would
still have delusional beliefs, but they'd
be about something else.
And this is something we've talked about with
experts on cultish behavior, conspiracies,
ism and believers in conspiracy theories.
Typically, these are folks who are prone to
these beliefs, and it's just sort of like
what's in their environment that they get
fixated on.
And that's why you see sometimes the flat
Earth.
People also believe the Jewish conspiracies,
Illuminati and vaccine microchips and on and
on and on because it's the same types of folks
who are often prone or susceptible to these
types of beliefs.
So very interesting voicemail from Amanda.
We're not diagnosing any particular individual
here, just Amanda's general assessment of
the delusional nature of some of these folks.
This is not like, and I think, you know, to
to really underline the difference here.
There is a difference between believing cutting
taxes for the rich is good for the economy,
right?
There's you can massage data to make that
case and then I can say no, but the data is
inaccurate.
If you believe Joe Biden was killed and replaced
with a body double in order to steal the election
from Trump, that is different.
There is a major difference between Oh, I
disagree with you on tax policy and you think
Biden's an imposter because the real Biden
was killed.
Those are not equivalent in any way, and there's
a difference between a political disagreement
and some of these delusional beliefs.
Speaking of delusional beliefs on the bonus
show, today, it looks like Florida Gov. Ron
DeSantis is signaling that he would support
a so-called the don't say gay bill.
It's been years since we've talked about these
don't say gay bills, and they're they're vile
and we're going to talk about it.
Also, a record 31 million Americans will be
betting on the Super Bowl.
Am I one of them?
Most of you probably know the answer, but
I'll answer it on the bonus show.
And also, there is an 85 mile wide comet heading
in our direction from the Oort Cloud.
Not going to hit Earth and not going to.
I'm not going to, you know, I know that there
are some people who, for the bonus show they
would do really dishonest things.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad, right?
Speaker 1: I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to pretend maybe this comet
is going to hit us.
It's not, but it's an interesting story nonetheless.
So all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
Sign up now at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Wow.
22 for a discount,
Unidentified: and I will see you.